i need to wipe my face you might not
care you might don't care
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
let's go guys
you're back with your boys
um james and fuhad keep it government
today
um
keep it government today we love you
guys well i hope you're having a good
monday yeah the chirps in the comments
is now becoming a fluid organic week on
week basis on week basis i don't know
who's knighted from it yet
if anyone
yeah guys just keep on pressing it okay
yeah man press the issue
and um yeah man breeding grounds church
sitting in the comments enjoy life live
lavish
um it's a vibe
and um yeah man if you're watching on
youtube you already know what to do
snuggle on over to that notification
bell
two fingers of death
click on that subscribe button like
chirp sitting in the comments
and if you're listening guys on your
monday morning commute
uh monday evening commute tuesday
morning commute whatever you're doing
get the time pull up on the side of the
road and leave us a nice review make
sure you're subscribing and you get the
automatic automatic downloads and last
but not least guys if you are one of the
many who are binging through the
episodes you're waiting waiting waiting
for the next one and you can't be asked
to wait till next monday
come on over to patreon it's patreon.com
forward slash [ __ ] and gigs
and then you're going to get yourself an
extra episode every thursday it's going
to cost you minimal
minimal amounts of money you're talking
three pound every 30 days that's 10 p a
day if you ain't got that quick maths 10
pence a day for some extra content guys
you get the showman over here on the
youtube you we play it up we laugh it up
backstage you get the real james and
fuzz man we speak we just we all we
speak on paper
we get deep from the heart of patreon we
always have a good time so if you're
only here for sng stay here if you want
the real james of through head come on
over to patreon we've got a community
over there and uh it's always a good
time
and i think that's about it so as you
started off the episode you were
speaking about government you said oh
we're gonna use our government names
today james yeah
yeah and it just reminded me of
something i saw on socials the other day
so um
uae i.e the united arab arab emirates ah
the united arab emirates government
announces a four and a half day working
week have you seen this
no i haven't so new systems to apply and
this is the fun fact by the way new
systems to apply in federal um governing
cities eight eight working hour days on
monday to thursday from 7 30 to 3 30 and
a four and a half working hour days on a
friday 7 30 to 12.
um obviously because of muslim country
friday sermons and prayers will be held
at 1 15 all year long in uae
possible possibility of flexible working
hours and working from home optional on
fridays longer weekends to boost
productivity and improve work-life
balance and this all starts in the first
of january 2022.
jealous
i say i'm jealous i don't work on nine
to five so it means nothing to me um but
in context in the context i will be very
jealous know what you mean i know
exactly what you mean because this is
something i'm pretty sure jeremy corbyn
was trying to do or was trying to push
um if he became
prime minister he wanted to definitely
do a four-day working week and
apparently when he suggested it in the
first place people laughed at it this
was pre-covered oh
he suggested this pre-covert i could be
wrong but i believe this is what i read
so you announced this pre-covered people
laughed at him or whatever blah blah
blah but obviously during kofi during
kovid everyone started to realize ah the
job i'm doing isn't what i really want
to do because i've got all the time in
the world and let me figure out how i
can make p
what else can make me happy and blah
blah blah obviously the more and more
people slowly started starting to go
back to work especially office based
work
you're thinking [ __ ] ah this is what am
i doing this is too sedentary for me i
don't like it here i don't like it here
i'm gonna be sitting down typing all the
time is dead and then the four day week
then i think
boris either boris or someone else
vocalized
vocalized another another um four day
week thing
but it was obviously a replica of what
jeremy said
but jeremy got brushed under the
shoulder blushed on the rug whereas i
think it was boris that said it um four
day week blah blah blah
obviously it didn't pan out but it was
like why is it relevant now that you're
saying it but when jeremy said it before
kovid it was like oh you get laughter
yeah yeah yeah but anyway four day week
four four and a half day week working
week in
dubai starting in
first of december first of january sorry
that 100 increased productivity oh
productivity lifestyle happiness so much
more man so much more i feel like it's
so
it's so under our
our day-to-day lives and our day-to-day
um like moods and morale is so
underrated when it comes to work oh fam
um okay um that's a lie let me not say
it's so underrated but it's
it's
it's taken what's the word i'm looking
for it's second best yeah yeah second
best to whatever the business and you're
working yeah yeah yeah always second
best even though we try our best to make
morale a number one thing especially in
things like hospitality when it comes to
actually groups of people working
together to achieve one thing whereas
when you worked in um sales
your sale didn't affect dolly sell next
to you do you know what i mean so
it's a very different dynamic whereas
obviously in hospitality you all have to
work together to make this thing
achievable so i can understand the
narrative of pushing the morale boosting
in those kind of businesses as opposed
to your more of your businesses but
within the same breath if for example
all hospitality venues closed on a
sunday
people would breathe
people would never be happy
saturday
in any hospitality business regardless
of the industry regardless of the name
of the brand
saturday will always be a busiest day
because it's a saturday yeah and no one
wants to work on a sunday especially
after work on a saturday yeah that's no
human it sounds like hail fam i'm not
doing it no human wants to do that i
i've hated it for so long for so long
but i still do it anyway there's nothing
to do with the companies i've worked for
it's just i hate doing it yeah this is
life
this is a fact
but yeah man they could have
i
i'm a strong believer of like between
four and six hour shifts
period not even just a four and a half
working day give me four hour shifts
period bro because like
if anyone anyone who's worked in the
office will know that like
no one's busy for the eight hours that
you're there you're chilling for time
fam just like you can in most office
jobs you can compress
the stuff across the eight hours if you
were working hard for four
like a solid i don't even know like or
even four and a half like two hours
solid take half an hour break and then
another two hour solid and go home bro
i'll be the most productive person ever
i'll be the most productive person ever
you can you can do that when it's eight
hours you're there all [ __ ] day first
thing in the morning until like
excuse me
first thing in the morning until five
o'clock at night and you're just like
big man
for a lot of this time as soon as i used
to come back from lunch we've said it
before i wanted to kip fam
my neck was rocking bro my neck used to
rock in deloitte as soon as i came back
from lunch i was done bro i was thinking
you're liking to get one email out of me
today every single day after lunch bro i
wanted to hide in the disabled fam if i
got in there at
nine
worked solidly to 11
took a half an hour break and then
worked from 11 or even [ __ ] 8 until
10
and then 10 30 till [ __ ] 1 30
whatever
bro or 12 30. i oh i will be productive
done in time for lunch
bro hella productive and then you just
get a second chipped in
for like you get half the people half of
them in there for the morning half a
minute yeah ain't costing anyone any
extra you pay them the same wage and
then you're open for the same hours or
whatever and you're just productive bro
everyone in there's ready you're
chilling because you might have to lie
in or you can have a leave early yeah
you're either leaving early or you've
had a fat lying and you're only there
for four hours yeah bro chilling but and
the thing is as well is like in cases
where
that's for cases that's perfect scenario
for people who
um
perfect scenario for people who just do
office jobs
that don't like require like um
a select amount of yeah a select amount
of teamwork or select amount of this or
that like whereas like you said for
sales for example
because you make commission on those
sales
and your
time there has a direct correlation to
the money that you make so if i'm
doing a four-hour day
there's another four hours in that day
that there's people i'm not seeing
there's people that i'm not speaking to
there's sales that i'm not making in as
far as i'm not there and that's going to
have a direct reflection on my paycheck
so for sales and stuff like that is
different because when your time is
directly correlated to your money
then i can choose to go in for four
hours if i'm happy to make 1100 pounds a
month which a lot of people aren't so if
i want to be making two two and a half
grand a month i can choose to be there
for eight hours
and then you're you still feel satisfied
with that because i'm here because i
want to be here because i want to make
more money yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's
how they used to
they used to make us because obviously
we live in [ __ ] england they used to
make you do eight hours anyway but
sometimes most of time i would be
chilling in there
and i would do my road shifts
from let's say i'm working monday to
friday
i would do my eight hours in there for
most of the day bro i was [ __ ]
chilling me and the boys would just make
up games and we'll just [ __ ] around for
hours bro there's times that me and my
boy would just play squash on the office
wall he would have a squash tracker i
would have a squash racket he'd sat on
that side of the office i sat on this
over there i said there's no wall there
and we'll just smack the ball to one
another just play squash we're bored fam
because we couldn't be bothered [ __ ]
because we're here for eight hours for
no reason yeah okay whereas
then even though i've worked monday to
friday yeah my manager could text me on
a saturday and say oh there's a family
here that you've been talking to they'll
want to sign up today if you want to
make this commission you you're going to
need to come in and sign them up and i
would drive all the way to milton keynes
just to make this money and that's my
day off yeah
so if if i didn't have a rotor or if i
only had to be there for three four
hours a day mandatory and for the rest
of the day or the rest of time i can
design my own rotor around that and it
directly correlates how much money i'm
making then i'm gonna be there more
anyway plus i'm feeling more motivated
because i feel like i'm here because i
wanna be not because i have to be
whereas when you feel like you're there
because well when you know you're there
because you have to be there but i'll
just sit and spin in my chair yeah
because it's just like this is pointless
i don't want to be here yeah i reckon a
lot of companies could benefit from like
a six hour work day or a four day week
or something like that bro because
here now i completely agree mum ah
there's mandatory hours
so boring so dead yeah so boring so dead
men said he played squash you know out
well we used to do the most amount of
[ __ ] that's wild to me james
would play games in the office we'd play
games and not do anything we'd play
catch we'd just play basketballs one
time my boss brought a pinata in and we
would start smacking up this pinata
where's where's your boss at she was
there why is he mad at playing squash
she's there yeah a lot of the time
sometimes she wasn't but obviously
there's a small team so she has to have
days off as well because you work
weekends in that job okay some days
you're off in the wee you're like so
sometimes there would be there'd be no
manager it would just be me and one of a
guy or two other guys and my manager
will be off so yeah we'll be [ __ ]
around bro okay and obviously you've got
minimum
kpis that you have to hit
so for example you had to make at the
time i don't know what it's now you had
to make 18 completed calls you had to
speak to 18 different people every day
if you really really want to you can get
that done in an hour
or you can do for one hour take an hour
off for another hour take an hour from
there for eight hours and get 18 done
across eight hours that means head once
you start [ __ ] around you'll be
surprised how fast the time goes of
course and then you'll check at the end
of the day and you've done three calls
and you've got half an hour left of your
shift fam you're just there
making [ __ ] up
but it's so weird i haven't worked there
for years yeah and i'm still nervous
about saying that that i used to do that
they're so stupid but oh make [ __ ] up
yeah yeah i'm like yeah this person is
there they're told this is a lies lies
that can never come back to you
you'd have to say that you spoke to them
yeah
but
for whatever reason they couldn't speak
to you because they were dropping their
kid off at school or something like that
but you couldn't say you couldn't say
you had like a good call because if that
comes back because they could walk in
the next day and then someone could like
oh you spoke to james on wednesday and
they'll be like who the [ __ ] is james
what are you talking about yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it could get bad and your
notes have details
you've got
reports of recording yeah yeah it's
recorded um
so yeah back in the days you'd have to
fluff it but we used to do nothing bro
but i'd still come in on my days off if
it was worth it yeah so i don't know why
they give you a writer there they should
basically say like bro you need to hit
your target to keep your job
anything over that
is your business you're you have to be
here between the hours of 10 and two or
you have to be in here between the hours
of or we need we need someone in the
office between these hours and you'll be
rotated on for two three hours at a time
to make sure there's always someone here
but apart from that do what the [ __ ] you
want and i would have been there eight
hours a day probably anyway yeah i would
feel more motivated because i'm here
because i want to be here yeah and then
yeah the rest of the man that just have
to be in the office
just make sure that ours are covered
and
chill
[ __ ] chill
i don't know
i like the sound of that i don't [ __ ]
know bro but i just feel like yeah
especially post covered a lot of people
will be more happy with either a four
day week or shorter days oh for sure man
for sure obviously this this will never
work in hospitality but in like office
based jobs 100
well i say hospitality it could work in
hospitality if they close on a sunday
and that's
i feel like everyone should just not
necessarily everyone's clothes on sunday
because people like to go out for food i
was going to say you literally just said
sundays are busy yeah sundays so your
company's going to lose money if they
close on a sunday
yeah but that doesn't necessarily affect
me yeah i know but
you know what i mean i know but what i'm
saying is is
in order to say
they should do something it has to
benefit anyone it has to benefit the
company as well as i know don't get me
wrong don't get me wrong sundays are
busy
um
but it's also
sometimes it's only very busy because of
the certain periods we're in
um i.e december christmas period or it
could be like a valentine's weekend or
it could be a specific thing like park
not necessarily parkland because if park
life is happening we're quiet because
everyone's gone to park life but certain
things could be happening so say if they
only open sundays in like december and
april or something i mean you know i
mean it's more relevant and you can
maximize the reason why you're open for
these amount of times yeah it wouldn't
make sense but yes of course the company
will of course every business will lose
money if you cut if you cut certain
things of course yeah but within the
same breath like this whole conversation
started because of morale true you know
if you want more out you want morale up
up like people will be happy to work for
you all day saturday knowing they've got
their sunday off i would 100 i wouldn't
care what shift i've got on a saturday
knowing i've always got sunday off and
i'll be fresh from monday to come and
record you know what i mean yes i would
not care what shift i do on a saturday
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that's how i felt
when i used to work at grill in the
market in london because we were always
closed on a sunday because we just went
open because of the location we're at um
it was a it was too close to so many
businesses that obviously business are
closed on a weekend so we're not going
to have customers on a weekend well on a
sunday really saturday's work open
because it's a saturday you have to open
whatever it is where it was and some
saturdays were quiet some saturdays were
[ __ ] ramps it was always a 50 50.
yeah yeah it was one of them ones but
sundays always closed and it was great
for morale guys stop what you're doing
there we need to shed some love on our
boys over at manscapes okay so guys as
we know it's the holiday season um that
means there are stockings to be stuffed
and elves to be cuffed
stockings to be stuffed and elves to be
cuffed let's go yeah man you already
know the vibes you already know what it
is
today sponsor manscaped
they've gone global with the tools to
guarantee you will score under the tree
and the mistletoe let's go
manscape is the leader we're talking
global leader in men's below the waist
grooming
and they've served more than four
million men worldwide it's doubled now
it's doubled up now i used to be posting
up two it's four now four now are we
directly responsible i can't say that
for a fact
who knows second biggest podcast in the
world is sent them double it's plausible
it's plausible i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna push that narrative but hey
guys do the math yeah um and if my math
is correct
that's almost eight million balls
eight million balls
have been served by your boys over at
manscape so if you want to join the
party
if you get fomo like i do yeah if you
want to have a proper christmas and you
want to stuff some stockings and cuff
some elves
get 20 off and free shipping from your
boys at manscape.com all you need to do
is put in the code sng sierra november
golf thank you sir
and you get yourself that discount and
free shipping that's manscape.com the
code is sng pause the video go over
there right now and collect your goods
just in time for christmas guys with
nothing else let's go back to the
episode let's leave it there go back to
the episode gang gang it was so great
for miranda but not all businesses do
that well morocco has a location the
company i work for now the pt
that i do my sister when i used to work
for them properly
a small period of time
where morale was up up
up
so
there used to be so basically the way
the the format worked is you'd always
work split shifts
so you'd work the morning and you'd work
the afternoon yeah so you'd work from
[ __ ] uh
like
7 30 in the morning until like 12 yeah
then you'd have a break from 12 till 4
and then you'd be back on at half four
till like eight or half eight don't make
me want to murder someone oh bro it was
deadly it was deadly but then they
turned around and were like and that was
monday to saturday
so you do a half a day saturday morning
so you're doing five and a half days a
week
so they changed it
and we're like cool this is how we're
going to change it like every if you're
working the saturday you get like
wednesday off
and then on top of that because
uh obviously being a pc company and they
like to have
everything across the board all the all
the different gyms when you're training
your clients you like to have like a set
plan
for everyone and obviously you make your
individual changes depending on the
client the plan for the day is this plan
for the day that takes a lot of admin
okay to get that done for the whole week
yeah so what they would do is
one trainer
every so it'd be one morning
um
for a week so let's say we had however
many trainers
you would have one morning off
to work from home and do these admin
tasks okay so you'll do the programming
for that week yeah yeah yeah for that
morning so every week all of a sudden
you've gone from work in split shifts
to now you've either got a saturday off
or if you have got the if you're working
saturday you've got like a wednesday off
so that you've got an extra day off for
the same amount of pee
and
every once one morning every week you're
working from home so you can have a
lay-in you can get up get the work done
as long as you get the work done before
your shift starts in the afternoon at
half four you're ch do you want
they will never check in on you just do
what the [ __ ] you want you just wake up
do your work and then turn up and as
long as the work is done to a higher
standard then there's no issues bro when
they made those changes because they
made those two changes at once
the morale went through the [ __ ] roof
everyone was productive i could imagine
no one was calling this sick nothing was
everyone was [ __ ] there because it
actually felt like these men are giving
me something here like i'm going to give
back but when you feel like they just
take take take take take
that
i'm taken
i'm taken literally literally wrong as
soon as he said call in sick bro that's
that's a constant trend in hospitality
oh i bet it is especially after like i
said saturday to sunday yeah no one
wants to be there on a sunday brother no
one bro that's the same when i used to
pt at another place back in the day
after the christmas party
no one was showing up no one was showing
up but there's another one of them
things it's like
people like um the managers used to get
so pissed off bro i remember ringing in
after one christmas fight i remember
ringing in yeah
to say
um
obviously it was a christmas spider the
day before i rang in the next day to
call in sick and the manager was like
james you're the third person to call in
sick
the next person to call in sick
is getting sacked so spread the word
because the next person that i pick up
this phone to is getting psyched
and i was thinking that's that's not my
problem i'm thinking i'm happy i wasn't
the fourth
god said i should call now
god said call in now her name was laura
she was jokes but found she was fed up
that day said next person to call in
sick is getting sacked
seek your fair play spread the word
i love that bro but yeah but i was a
perfect example of
oh we want you to come in after the
christmas party don't call in sick or
whatever but everyone else was like why
wouldn't i
what do you ever do for me like
literally what do you do for me nothing
all you just take from me take from you
take from me you make me work well you
always ask me to work overtime always
ask me to help help help help always
taking like my days off from me asked me
to come in on this and what the [ __ ] do
you ever do for me nothing so when push
comes to shove and i want to pull a
sickie because i'm hungover you best
believe i'm pulling a sickie i'm not
coming in because you do [ __ ] all for me
but when a company gives and gives and
gives
you want to give back give back of
course because you believe in the
company yeah you don't necessarily
believe in what they're trying to sell
you just necessarily believe in how they
treat other people the culture give it
the culture the give and take that's
what it's all about you know it's um
it's tough morale is a
is a big thing in any industry man any
industry you have to you have to make
sure your staff are looked after oh bro
and it's tough as a manager because
for me even though
my morale is up and down depending on
the day depending how much i've slept or
whatever my mood is i have to try and
make sure my staff members are okay
which is annoying because it's like
they reap all the rewards from
the hard work we put in yes don't get me
wrong they put they put in ten times
more hardware because they're the one
serving a guest like the chefs are
cooking the food blah blah blah it's
easy to say as a manager that i'm not
putting in hard work even though i am
but within the same breath
they would never have to do a close they
will never have to do an open they will
never have to understand what it's like
to stay
after everything's closed like you know
counting the cash all these little
things coming in on your day off coming
in to do this coming in to do that and
it's like
yes it's a knowledge for me to
make my day better but it doesn't change
my wage at the end of the month yeah bro
so everything you're telling me to do
yes i can understand it might help me
this month or help us this month or
whatever it's not really a morale
booster
you know like let's take december aside
because december is the busiest month in
any hospitality business and that's
where you're most likely gonna make the
most money and bonuses and blah blah
blah let's take a random month
like it's still
if you're putting in the same workers
still asking us to do this and asking us
to do that we're not gaining anything
from it oh as a manager you're not
gaining anything from it like the staff
might gain something from it every day
because the staff get the tips yeah the
staff get to have a half date you can do
an 11 6 and dip you can do a foreclose
and have the morning off like big man
i'm doing i'm coming in at 11 i'm not
leaving until 11.
do you know what i mean yeah bro i'm
exactly the same that's how i used to
feel with that office job that i told
you about obviously when i was working
in the sales job like you said
anything extra they asked me to do could
potentially have a benefit
to my paycheck so i'd be willing to do
it because it means i could get paid
more money
um
whereas on the
office job that i worked a couple years
ago
um before i quit that to do this
bro all the time we'll be like oh we're
behind on targets guys like
um for the next like four hours if you
could just like
wrap up whatever you're doing i'm gonna
give you this task and they basically
want you to kill yourself to get back up
to where they should be on like the kpis
and all this stuff like we need to be
here by the end of the day like
finish whatever you're doing and get on
this task and like let's crush it and
they'll push you push you push you push
you push you and they're like cool cool
and at the end of the day they're just
like yes guys we did it it's like
that means [ __ ] all to me it literally
[ __ ] up it means [ __ ] all to me
because i get paid salary so
you're killing me for the rest of the
day and at the end of the day
i think the narrative is slightly
different because in that aspect it will
be the managers who get rewarded for
that when the managers get the staff
to do all the extra work to get back on
target when the month ends and we're on
target the managers get a bonus the
staff get nothing
um and it's the staff that do all the
work whereas that's the opposite for you
is that the staff will get the tips
stuff will get more money the staff will
get over time instead of whereas you
you do all the extra stuff and you get
nothing that's exactly how it is but in
the opposite side of our office is where
like the ground workers do all the extra
work get [ __ ] all for it
and the managers get the bonuses every
month because we're on target yeah um
it's [ __ ] bro [ __ ] halfways yeah
and then eventually after about six
months once i closed it because i'd come
from sales to that and i clocked like
bro i felt like i was in the matrix
because i was saying to my mate like why
are we doing this obviously to hit
target and all that stuff i was like
yeah yeah but why though because
if we're off target what does it mean to
me nothing if we're on target what does
it mean to me nothing the only
difference is i work really really hard
in one aspect or i chill any other
aspect and i'm still here for eight
hours and i'm still getting paid the
same so i can either chill
and work nine to five or i can work
really hard for nine to five i'd rather
chill because at the end of the day it
means focal to my paycheck it means [ __ ]
up to my head space it means [ __ ] up to
nothing why would i work hard for no
reason it doesn't make any sense but no
one really thinks of it that way it's
just like oh boss said i have to do it
so i'll do it
naji
if i'm working hard and i always relate
to this now i always relate like
if
you asked me like james i really need
you to do this thing
for the pod or we really need to do this
thing for wednesday thursday friday it's
gonna take us like six hours every day
from thursday friday like wednesday
thursday friday this week it's going to
be so much more extra work than we're
used to
i know on the back of it you've got
money for you whatever you're asking me
to do is going to significantly affect
me because there's no way you can make
me work eight hours a day for three days
which is nothing in the normal working
life yeah but on this and not telling me
that it's going to give me x amount
extra every month it definitely will
there's just no there's no conceivable
reason why i wouldn't i wouldn't even
bring it to the table otherwise exactly
so but in the office space it doesn't
mean that they just care about how much
money the company makes
a company needs to make more p which
means nothing to me and their reward to
you is you get to keep your job
this whole thing is the baby you say
what's in it for me you get to eat
tonight that's what's in it for you
oh it makes me want to punch something
oh my days bro um yeah it's tough mum
bro yeah it's friday it's real harsh um
you had you said you had a twitter
thread yeah um for more light-hearted
stuff yeah
so i've said before twitter's the
funniest place on earth
yeah i'm slowly learning actually
twitter is the funniest place on earth
fam like before you get into it jacob
sent me a a tweet earlier
i haven't laughed that hard
in a very very long time
it was said it's over yours i'll show
you
i have to we might have to get ellis to
block out the
music
okay um just for copyright reasons yeah
yeah but it's like um there's a bit of a
jerk trend coming back around okay have
you seen it um no
i've seen one jerk video
but yeah there's a bit of a there's a
bit of a jerk train coming around and he
sent me this okay now i've definitely
not seen this
and let me see it closely
so watch the video tell me when you
finish watch the video yeah
yeah
yeah okay and now
i'll read what the caption says
one guy replied
this is how the hunter examiner was
running in the first hunter exam
that's
into the mist that's exactly how he was
waiting he sent me that this afternoon i
was in tears bro
in tears oh that's hilarious funniest
thing and i said bro
the general public are the funniest
comedians of all time of all time bro
the comparisons people make sometimes
are hilarious bro
[ __ ] in hell right
thank you for that bro that was
hilarious
right so time for
uh someone tweeted time for hall time
for another hall of fame tweet and
there's bag of quote tweets and bagger
likes
so i'm gonna read some of the replies
they're [ __ ]
hilarious um i'll start i'll start with
something like it says [ __ ] started
only fans pages thinking you're gonna
pop off now you you now know what it
feels like to be a local rapper
fan
we get dms
from local rappers dms always there's
always links in my inbox fam
check out my music
that's painful
but yeah so some of these only fans
something only fans like they lose their
morale quick
they start off thinking it's just going
to be a couple foot pick here and
they're going to make cake no
next thing they're spreading cheeks
anything cause then
no one cares
literally no one cares
someone tweeted
missionary because she doesn't wipe good
a lie
it's disgusting it's horrific missionary
because she doesn't wipe good
that's that's [ __ ] disgusting that's
disgusting yuck
photoshop
after getting the bbl is the type of
greed they talk about in the bible
about this
i've read this about four times i've
laughed the same oh my god every single
type of wrestler is funny i read this on
the trade here again i was like this is
funny too funny
it's the type of green they
[Laughter]
that is funny bro
[ __ ] that's making me laugh
i just want to know why
i just want to know why do i see [ __ ]
who owe me money feeding their kids
[Laughter]
i'm sweating oh wow these are slaying
still these are good um
all right there's this i don't uh you
might not have seen it but i saw this
time ago i remember seeing this years
ago
there's a picture
of a girl
in uh she's in like a one-piece suit
she's got arse up and there's a massive
pizza next to it and the caption is what
are you eating first someone quote
someone quote tweeted that and said this
you're a cindy
is that what you want to hear that will
eat your [ __ ] before you eat the
pizza you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
stop
that's so funny
oh
jesus christ that's too funny
all right [ __ ] who get arrested for
murder rape molestation should get bbl's
before they get tossed into prison i bet
that brings the crime rate down
they will get
absolutely doggied
nah
nah
that's me oh my god i'm actually
sweating james i can see it i'm
[ __ ] it out
oh it's the funniest thing
i think dudes that feel weird around gay
dudes are gay you got to think about it
you can put me in a room full of the
purest crack i wouldn't even look twice
why because i'm not a crackhead and now
you put a crackhead in that position you
see where i'm going shaking
he's so vexed
that's actually facts people who hate
gay guys are gay i must be a million
percent oh my god i'm fine i'm hot i can
see it bro i'm hot i don't think you
understand what some water's on your
face right now you're glistening
it reminds me of the time i was shaking
on the boat fam it's down your neck and
everybody can sit on your throat
[ __ ] you now you can see my sweat on my
throat
oh [ __ ]
oh
fam oh hold on
i'm i can't
i actually can't
have that cindy
[Laughter]
man feels so betrayed by his own libido
so frustrated by it
is something you want to hear you
[ __ ]
i need to wipe my face you might not
care human don't
[Laughter]
that's i don't think you understand how
much that one's made me laugh
you know that will eat your ass before
the pizza
fam
that
i
feel that guy's pain yeah because you
don't want tick-tock
that trend that was like i want to know
if i came to our first date wearing this
what would you do yeah frustrate you
yeah yeah yeah would you think
what do you think
i hate it i hate it
because it breaks me down to my most
primal friend yeah i know exactly what i
want to know if i came out to shop
you know what i'm going to do
and i hate that i'm going to do it
oh it's so annoying you know you're
banging
shut up ask me dumb questions
basically you'd ask me dumb questions
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you reminded your business enjoying life
being broke then here comes someone's
high maintenance daughter talking about
they have a crush on you said not now
lord
fam
there's cheeks i've had in my life
that i was thinking
she could ask me for a bag and i don't
know what i'm gonna do
you start contemplating if the bag is
worth the next beat i know what she's
expecting
and i'm thinking what am i gonna say
what am i gonna do
i can't lose this
nah
oh
it's too funny
it's too funny i'm sweating james i
don't think you understand i'm sweating
under this jumper
[Music]
[ __ ] hell
i think that's it for now i'm there's
loads more all right but i'll save them
for another day fair play that's the f
this is the funniest thread bro fan
twitter is the funniest place on earth
twitter is funny bro as soon as i saw
that that jerk thing earlier i was i was
twisted up bro i couldn't believe it
it's just not on um
i love that book so i've got one
let me breathe
let me actually breathe for a second
i've got a fan request oh somebody
[ __ ] okay i didn't even know it was
right
my boyfriend so am i the [ __ ] right
my boyfriend 22 and i 20 have been
together excuse me for over a year and
pretty much lived together uh for the
same amount of time
his family loves me and mine loves him
everything is perfect but he doesn't
want his best friend
in brackets they're really close well
it's his best friend so obviously he
doesn't want his best friend to come
over when i'm there his last
relationship was toxic
um in brackets he was the secret
boyfriend
and now i feel like he wants to hide me
too
he said he just prefers it that way
even though he met all of my friends
pretty soon after we got together am i
the [ __ ] for feeling like i'm not
good enough to meet his friend
um
ps lovely podcast
pps
i'm 20 and i've already had a threesome
you guys are clearly doing something
wrong way you read that you went from
here and you sunk bro you were sinking
when you read that
how antagonizing do you want to be
i'm 20 i've already had a threesome
you're clearly doing something wrong
[ __ ] off the audacity first let's just
let's address that first
i'm not doing anything wrong it's just
the way life is
it's just the way life is just how it is
secondly she's a chick a chicken get a
threesome with anyone tomorrow two girls
three guys five guys six girls it
doesn't matter she's she's new in the
game bless her she doesn't understand
okay doing something wrong shut up shut
up that's what i said earlier sharp
sharp because it's i don't need to
entertain nonsense
i just don't i just don't need to say
nonsense
fair point right so yeah it's the yeah
because her and man have been together
for a year
um they've been living together for
basically a year as well we won't unpack
that um
and
yeah she's never met his best friend or
if she has she doesn't she basically
doesn't want the friend over or
something when yeah so they live
together but he will never invite his
best friend over when she's there she's
there because he just um because he used
to be a secret boyfriend or whatever and
he's just insecure about his best friend
and his girl
being in the same house apparently even
when he's there
um
so is she ourselves for feeling like
she's not good enough to meet his best
friend um i don't necessarily think he
she's an [ __ ] for that because she's
not in control of
his feelings in that aspect so she can't
be an answer for that if that makes
sense yeah being also for him
for his actions or his lack of actions
she can't be an answer for that um i can
understand
why she might think she's an [ __ ]
purely because she does she's not
getting introduced but plain and simple
the answer is no in my opinion the
answer is no yeah it seems weird like if
he's if he's introduced to the family
and you guys live together i just i feel
like her feelings are misguided yeah
yeah yeah like when i read that
at not one point does it make me feel
like he doesn't think she's good enough
to meet the best friend it sounds like
he doesn't trust his boy or some [ __ ]
like that the first time you obviously
read it twice now the first time you
read it it made it seem as if not
necessarily made it seem as if but it
made me think that because
he was a secret boyfriend in the past
that
the
boyfriend number one was probably his
boy or a friend or someone that he maybe
yeah that's the reason why he doesn't
want to
meet he doesn't want his current girl to
meet his current best friend in his in
my opinion it sounds like he's
maybe jealous of his boy over his best
friend and for god knows what it means
yeah he might feel like he's he'll lose
his girl
to him yeah if he meets his girl he
might think yum yum
that's what it sounds like but i would
never take it i'm not good enough to
meet his best friend
you could take it from the perspective
maybe he thinks yeah like on the same
side of it of like oh maybe he thinks
that his boy will try and move to her
maybe
because he knows girls can cheat
he might not want he might think his
friend is buffer than him
and might not want his girl to meet his
friend because he's already been the
side man before and he knows what girls
are capable of and like she said ha ha
ha she's out of threesome and she's 20.
yeah family you're bragging about your
sexual history to two strangers you've
never met yeah what knows what you're
telling your man exactly um so yeah yeah
that's fun on you yeah yeah that spawn
on you back don't put us on the hot seat
this is our show
but um yeah i wouldn't tell you you
should feel like you're not good enough
to meet his friend it seems like there's
you know it sounds like your mom's just
got trust issues
he needs to address i'm sure he does uh
he sounds like a [ __ ] to be perfectly
honest he he does sound like a [ __ ] but
it's also one of them ones where you're
very young well this is me talking about
the guy not the girl obviously like he's
very [ __ ] young like 22. he's 22 he's
had a previous relationship where he was
the sighting he's trying to
be in a relationship now or he is in a
relationship now lives with the girl
22 that's young bro that's young you
guys haven't had time to
find out about yourselves yet and you're
living with someone else i feel less
for me personally there are a lot of
factors here that
are just
not in my head space or not in my
dynamic light i wouldn't live with
someone
at the age of 22.
now like i think that changes a lot
about something like you've not found
your feet you don't know what you you
don't know so many things about your
life yeah but yeah i don't know it's
hard for me to say because
well i have lived with someone when i
was 22 and it was trash so
there you go there you go and i didn't
want to be there there you go it's just
uh yeah it's tough man different man
yeah i would yeah i would say that
he needs to be more self well clearly
he's got some
issues
uh with trust and his insecurities
oh for sure this is all based on him
yeah for sure and the fact that you guys
live together like you're at that stage
of a relationship but he still has these
insecurities that's something he needs
to address himself so you should
probably just tell him like no offense
but like you're being a [ __ ] or you'll
be like this is not normal bravo yeah
and regardless of this whole like oh i
would just prefer it that way and he's
probably trying to belittle it and make
it seem like it's not a big deal it's
like listen it's no big deal like you
don't need to he's my friend not yours
you don't need to meet him it's whatever
like he doesn't understand that it's
like big man you're insecure as [ __ ] and
like i don't want a man
who's insecure like that that's baby
chat yeah what are you on about yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're clearly
scared about me meeting your boy that's
[ __ ] or behavior stop that that's icky
the ick right
yeah i could never i could never tell my
wife's
she said oh what am i gonna make foohard
you don't need to be dead why i just i
just prefer if you didn't
yuck
you said why and then and then if he
asked why and i have to if she asks why
and i have to be like well you know
you know my past i've been
someone's little secret before it's not
it's not comfortable i'm just not sure
how i feel about uh it's just my own
issue i'd just prefer if you didn't meet
if you had all together
your [ __ ]
stop
that's the whole thing that's like when
[ __ ] girls go through your phone and
you're like what the [ __ ] are you doing
she's like i've been cheated on before
shut up
that doesn't make any of this acceptable
yeah it doesn't it really doesn't it
really literally shut up um so no i
would say you're not the [ __ ] for
feeling that way but
you definitely do need to tell your man
to like snap out of it
and but like yeah there's literally no
way that we can continue at this level
in the relationship if i'm not even
allowed to meet your friends your best
friend your best friend you live
together big man you guys live together
yeah that's as high as it gets it
doesn't get any more than that
so the boys only around the yard loud
around the yard when you're not there
nah man that's dead that is and it's
it's just
it's such a weird dynamic because these
are two this is again for the guy these
are two people that you care about
quote-unquote the most the girl you're
living with and your best friend or not
the most but you know what i mean yeah
man they're up there they're up there in
the rankings so it's like
why can't they be in the same room so
you know it's um it's it's clearly not
your fault you are not the [ __ ]
darling but it's something you have to
address to him if you don't he's not
experiencing himself if you don't
address to him then you have to leave
him because it just happened
you just have to leave yeah because it
starts with this and then exactly when
there's things like this this this will
never be the end of it exactly this is
why you have to leave him now um because
there's always going to be more things
he's not going to want you to do yes
when you when people have insecurities
that are irrational
it never ever ever just stays with one
thing
when they have that kind of trait yeah
it will spread like wildfire to
everything yeah yeah next thing brav
he'll be telling you what you can and
can't wear out
and then he'll be saying if you want to
go out i'm going to be picking you up
yeah and i need to know what time you're
going to be home and then you'll be
asking why why why and he'd be like well
i was the second boyfriend she used to
meet me at 11 o'clock
she'd tell her proper boyfriend that she
was such and such when she was at my
house i know how these things go i need
to be picking you up so i know you're
safe
these things get worse and worse and
worse now yeah yeah now yeah you're not
addressing it leave him now that's what
i'm saying darling
yeah man it's it's it's not on that card
it's really not that can't run at all
but [ __ ] yeah i broke sweat in the
episode i know you did
um
i actually
i was gonna take a week off okay but
you're boiling through the comments
okay you know we i love him i know from
all right let's ignic
so
see some of these are actually okay cool
so this is at the point where now
some of them are they're all funny but
some of them are just
too petty yeah and it's time for us to
fight back
sorry okay it really is time for us to
fight back that's hilarious yeah all
right
one
when he can't get the chocolate out of
the advent calendar
fam
so pathetic
but i think i've read that one this is a
comment from a video this is a comment
from a video fam
have you ever once asked me how that
advent card oh yes i don't know
i had one probably three years ago i
hate them but i probably had one like
three years ago
getting that chocolate out when you go
to scrape it and you just scratch
chocolate off the top it goes under your
nail and nothing's moved
i want to lob the whole thing
it's so infuriating yeah and you have to
try and tip it and tap tap it out yeah
yeah and you can't even break the tin
foil
[ __ ] behavior but
specific too specific we need to fight
back
there's not that i'm not having that
yeah not having that
this one
this one's an ick if i've ever seen one
bro
when he takes the wrong seat at the
cinema and gets told to move
[Laughter]
fam
thank god that's never been it never
happened to me
it's never happened
to me and the thing is as well i've
always thought
when it comes this is the thing
when it comes to cinema dates that i've
had in the past when i was younger like
teens maybe early 20s
like
i've been on a date with a girl would be
like let's just sit anywhere
[Music]
or she'll be like i'll be like when
you're in you're booking the season like
where do you want to sit i don't care
and then she'll just go sit i'm not r
i'll see you guys i'll be that guy but
rc's over there we're e-26 um
and should look at me like yuck
like why it's just a [ __ ] seat like
why do you care the reason i care is
because i'm gonna sit in the next man
seat for man to roll up to me and tell
me move
and i refuse to move
because i'm with my lady friend and i'm
thinking there's no way next man can
shake me up i don't care if he's paid
for the seat yeah yeah once i'm sat here
i'm not moving yeah i don't i don't want
to have a physical confrontation in a
[ __ ] cinema
there's just no way so i will always
rather be the [ __ ] first yeah and like
we're sitting here so she has more time
to get over it rather than accept her
decision sit in the seat she wants for
next man say get up
and then we've got a situation
because now you're fighting in the dog
now i'm fighting in the dark and i could
get smacked up and moved out my seat
and then be scrambling for my ticket to
look where we're supposed to sit with
the torch
the movie's just going fam
the opening credits have roald fam and
i'm just scat room for my ticket to see
where we're supposed to sit
ah too embarrassing and i think it could
get double worse
because if you sit if you don't know
where you're supposed to be sitting you
sit in next man's seat he shafts you up
you could end up sitting in another
mansion and get told to move again
oh your life's over you'd have to leave
i'd leave the cinema i'd leave the
cinema babes we're not watching this
movie today let's go
i'll tell you just dump me now
let's just get this process over with
and dump me now because there's no way
you can hear about this there's no way
you can get moved up out of two seats
and expect to see her again no way
that is one for me that's top five most
valid ex i think i've ever read on this
show
top five most valid eggs i went as soon
as i read it outside oh yeah that's
perfect
this one if you're if you're in school
this one's the most valid dick you're
gonna get
when the top of the bus is packed and he
has to go back downstairs
james
duncan you don't know how many times
that's happened to me in secondary
school bro
it's so embarrassing it is embarrassing
it's so it's even more embarrassing when
you get on an equally packed bus with
loads of people waiting at the bus stop
and you think [ __ ] you're one of the
first people on the bus [ __ ] it i'm
gonna go upstairs no space upstairs but
you have to turn back round and there's
about 17 man behind you oh it comes
behind you trying to get upstairs like
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
there's no space and everyone can see
your head there saying no space there's
no space there's no space there's no
space there's no space
and you just you just have to be that
[ __ ] looking down telling everyone
there's no space you have to wait for
seventeen man to move will you go back
downstairs oh
that's so embarrassing embarrassing it's
so embarrassing bro when you get up that
spiral stare and you just look over the
bar
and you can see there's no spaces
and then you look down you're like oh my
god my life's over
my life's over and there's always a
painting waiting down there
my life's over i'm pretty interested the
boston you've been exchanging eyes fam
she sat downstairs
like a proper citizen and you come back
down the stairs and there's no seats
down there either and you just said
standing there
sitting on that disabled step
like a yeah
never that that is bringing up painful
memories it is it is i'm glad i never
luckily i didn't have to take the bus to
school so it was rare that i haven't
ever had to go through that but when i
did ah agony
i can imagine agony it was tough man it
was [ __ ] bro [ __ ] agony
do you know there's another ick specific
to the bus
same is it it's exactly the same as when
you're in the cinema okay
when you're on the bus on a at a sunny
july and you pull open the window and
next man tells you to close it
when you're 15. fan finn hot fam you
kiss your teeth pull open a window and
big donnie says i close the window man
and you don't even know who said it you
just heard decibels
and
you don't know what to do
i hear you but that's not even the worst
one oh god tell me the worst one is
because
when you
when you open the window on the top on
the top deck
especially if you open the window right
where you're in the back seat obviously
the breeze is hitting you at the back
let's say i'm on the back back of the
bus top deck yeah yeah i've opened the
window in front of me yeah so the breeze
gonna hit me yeah yeah it's ten times
worse when i've opened the window i'm
relaxed and the brother in the seat
there slams him
[ __ ] slams it what do you do
brother johnny doesn't even look back he
slams it and faces falling
[Laughter]
you're just there like right you just
have to accept it fam that's happened to
me more than once
i want a real naked choking i want to
[ __ ] choke him because that's
that's a confrontation you want
did you not just see me open the window
the man just doesn't look back doesn't
just bang bang
that's confidence
that's confidence
comfort i was 14 i didn't have that that
back then i couldn't open it again i
didn't want that confrontation of course
because as soon as you open it again fam
fight
as soon as i've opened it again
my heart would quake james
[Laughter]
the look back would make me quake a
young 14 15 year old two hat i'm not on
it
i'm not on it like that
i'm not on it like that
this man drew for the second window
he didn't have a slightly look back
hard shut up fam
i'd press the bell so i can get off
before my stop my school honey boo could
never
ever
ever
see next man close my window
i couldn't i couldn't especially if
you're sitting next to her fam you meant
a chin
you pull it open one more time sam looks
back
shaking huh
she's he's looking at me she's looking
at me i don't know what to look fam i
wouldn't know where to look
i'm just there
he doesn't even turn around you just
look back shoulder thing there
there's nothing you can do it's not a
[ __ ] day you see it again that's the
look he's giving me i [ __ ] dare you
to do it again
you small little brick oh no no no no
fam there's nothing worse than trying to
then
experiencing testosterone in your body
but realize you're still a boy
you're still a boy
i remember
i remember when i was in year seven yeah
your boy's getting into his skin a
little bit yeah it was a snow day yeah
a [ __ ] snow day yeah i thought i was
bad yeah i don't know why i just thought
i was bad i was running around with my
boy kevin on the way home or walking
home from school snowden as a cyclist he
must have been in his 50s cycling up the
street and my boy said let's snowball
him i was like gang that sounds funny
fam
he was sucking up the road minding his
own business my boy goes oi mate
lobbed the snowball i loved the snowball
he said yeah from got off his bike and
[ __ ] chased us we're running running
running
and he he does we split up yeah he
decides to go for my boy so i stop yeah
and i'm like ryan bro run and he
my boy dips
couldn't catch him so he turns around
and sees me waiting there
i'm like 11 fam he walks up the road and
he just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger as he closes closer he gets he
thinks he goes yeah do you think that's
[ __ ] funny
i was stuttering man i said
pat popped me in my head dropped me to
the floor i bounced on my ass
he bust me in my head and i bounced my
ass on the floor
no
no girl from my year could have seen
that bro i'm surprised he didn't run
he was from him yeah when he's when he
turned around and he said you saw him
because
there was nowhere to run but up the road
and it's snowing fam i would have
slipped okay so we were on a residential
street okay there's no side alleys
there's nothing can you even go down the
road because it's like a steep hill okay
either go down where kevin went yeah my
boy chased him but because he carried on
chasing him i didn't i wasn't thinking i
just stopped running because i knew he
went chasing me anymore not thinking
he's gonna turn around and come back and
i'm gonna be stuck here
so it's either that is evil wait for him
to thump me up or try turn around and
slip on the ice because i 100 would have
yeah the panic would have consumed you
that you froze you could have ran up
like that
you would have ran all that back yeah
fam he came up popped me in my forehead
put them on my arse and biked off
and that's the closer you got the bigger
i couldn't imagine it i couldn't imagine
it pop me square on my forehead i was so
close to tears
and i made me realize i'm a child yeah
that's a man
that's a there was nothing i could do as
soon as we face the face already there's
nothing i can do
that was mortality in his essence
there's nothing you can do yeah he can
do what he wants to meet here there's
nothing i could do you [ __ ] tell me
what's up
i fell i bounced twice on my ass and
just looked up still shaking forehead
swelling backpack
backpack on school trousers merch soaked
through
so embarrassing there's no way a female
from my school could have drove past or
walked past there hadn't seen that never
no i would have broken down i would have
broken down
um next one oh
when there's no cars around but he still
waits for the green walk sign
that's not fair there's one i did see it
could be on your list as well
uh what was it what was it what was it
when he
i think maybe a guy wrote it for a girl
when he tries to
no a girl wrote a guy wrote it from a
girl's for a girl
when she leaves the car
and tries to slam my door but it doesn't
slam so he has to then reach out close
open it yeah yeah yeah you're fighting
along the way yeah yeah yeah
somewhere and that's reminding me
because he said discarding now yes bravo
so annoying um oh this one this one's a
massive [ __ ] ick
sweetened me
when he drinks a glass of water and you
can see his open mouth through the
bottom of the glass
just
just go i've seen that so many times
through hat
i've seen that so many times
it's [ __ ] disgusting because you can
see the ripple of the wave as the water
goes down and comes back up and their
[ __ ] gullet it's so disgusting male
or female
ick oh god yeah
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
when he holds his nose before going
underwater
you absolute [ __ ] damn you're a [ __ ]
i've seen that if you can't exhale when
you go in there it's i think it's that's
probably me
if i'm to this day
if i'm pencil diving yeah or i'm bombing
yeah your boy's nostrils are clutched
yeah claps clasped yeah have to i don't
know it's just it's just it just i know
it's a nick yeah i know there's so much
a man can do in a pool that turns women
off oh yeah for sure the short thing fam
the inflated shorts
humiliating holding your nose
humiliating the swimming towards you
humiliating bag of splashing fam
when you come up and you just got snot
you're just humiliating quick
family whitebeard you've got that one
there
humiliating
humility
there's a lot there's a lot that can go
wrong for a man in a pool yeah a man
shouldn't a man
who has a sexual appetite doesn't belong
in swimming
a man with any sense of sexual appetite
does not belong in a swimming pool
that's a fact
disgraceful brother that's hilarious
backstroke ick
breast stroke breaststroke ache
that's what i think she's saying i'm
thinking breath stroke
if you've got frog legs in the
breaststroke
egg unless you're professional what you
do
don't breaststroke oh that's hilarious
yeah bro real man doesn't belong in the
pool oh my god it's painful but it's
true we've laughed today we have we have
we have today we have [ __ ] now the
photoshop bbl greeting
the bible thing that i've never laughed
so hard every time i read it i laugh
exactly the same fam that's two jokes
twitter is actually it's the best of the
best it's the funniest medium bro i
don't get it people like you said the
people general public fam
the way they see the world is the
funniest [ __ ]
i said that's the type of greed that he
talked about
it's not fair they come up with stuff
it's not fair how funny that is jesus
christ
that broke me oh guys
so we said this before
you have to own your ex yeah mom if we
call your name just stand up yeah just
raise your hand one of the two some of
them are getting so petty that we can't
even bear it anymore
i know this is that i don't want to
dishearten the guys
but you man keep sending in x that one
i've heard a million times before and
two just aren't they're not
funny they're not hidden they're two
that's the thing the reason the girls
ones are so funny is because they're so
pathetic
the guys are actually valid a lot of the
time but they're not
it's not punchy they're just not what
we're looking for yeah yeah we're
looking for like the nuances yes yeah
the ones that think that's so relevant
but who thinks of that exactly exactly
that's what we're looking for
and guys you're letting the squad down
oh yeah you really really are um but it
is what it is maybe this just isn't our
forte
maybe it's just not our forte maybe not
um
but hey ho what can we do bro yeah mum
what can we do guys
this has been a great monday it has
gonna love you and leave you yeah we'll
catch you on the next one um
make sure you subscribe flick that
notification notification bell
chirp sitting in the comments comment
over to patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs let's have a good time on
thursday and
yeah man love love love
[Music]